[Musique]
déjà l'on demande à un an au sénat un
engagement tout terrain ici dans de
multiples commissions délégations comme
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire la réalisation des droits des
femmes est plus gagner moi ça manque de
promptitude pour l'aviation civile
pourrait forer chasse et pêche voilà un
engagement tout terrain pour être
ensuite évidemment utile aux territoires
engagement tout terrain et engagement
sur le terrain je reste bien des gens
présents
vers les élus les communes participation
à de nombreuses réunions de conseils
municipaux rencontre avec les élus être
utile pour faire avancer leur dossier et
puis bien moins en demande un cd
l'occasion au moins dû rendre compte de
ce mandat j'ai adressé ce mois-ci
4300 et lui de la vienne le compte rendu
de cette première année d'activité
[Musique]